Let's systematically name some
carboxylic acids, so let's add
a molecule that looked
like this.
Clearly a carboxylic acid,
we have a carboxyl
group right over here.
Now to name it systematically,
we do it just the way we've
named our simple alkenes.
When we first learned how to
name any organic molecule, you
look for the longest
carbon chain.
And the longest carbon chain
is one, two, three, four
carbons, so our prefix will
be but-, so it's butan.
Instead of calling it butane,
instead of writing this e
here, we know this is a
carboxylic acid, it has this
carboxyl group, so
we butanoic acid.
And you might wonder, don't we
have to specify where the
carboxyl group is?
And if you look at how
carboxylic acids are arranged,
you can tell that the carboxyl
group is always going to be at
one end of a carbon chain, so
you don't have to specify.
In fact, you always want to
start numbering at wherever
the carboxyl carbon is.
So if you have to number these,
this would be the one
carbon, the two, the three,
and the four.
So you don't have to specify a
number for the carboxyl group.
Let's do another one.
Let's say we had something
that looked like this.
Let me put another carbon on
there, just like that, and
let's say that there's
a methyl group.
Now clearly, a carboxylic
acid, but to name it
systematically we just want to
find the longest carbon chain.
So we have one, two, three,
four, five, six carbons, so
our prefix will be hex-,
so it's hexan.
It's clearly not just a hexane,
it's a hexanoic acid,
it has this carboxyl
group right here.
This is hexanoic acid.
And we're not done, because we
still have this methyl carbon
right over here, and it is on
the-- we always want to start
numbering at this
carbonyl carbon.
One, two, three, four,
five, six.
It is at the number three
carbon, so this is 3 methyl
hexanoic acid.
Let's do one more.
Let's say we had a molecule
that looked like this.
That's one, two, three, four,
five, six, seven carbons.
Then we have our carboxyl group
just like that, and
let's say that we had a double
bond right over there.
What would we call this?
Well, once again, look for
the longest carbon chain.
We have one, two, three, four,
five, six, seven carbons, so
the prefix is hept-,
so it's heptan.
And actually let me be careful,
this isn't an alcane.
This has a double
bond right here.
So it's hepten.
If this was just an alkene, we
would just called heptene, but
we're not going to put this last
e here, because this is
the carboxylic acid.
And to specify where that double
bond is, we need to
start numbering, and we
start numbering at
the carbonyl carbon.
One, two, three, four,
five, six, seven.
So you could either name this
3 hepten, and I haven't
finished it yet, I haven't put
this final e over here.
Or you could name it hept
3 ene, just like that.
This is the more typical one
that you would see, because it
tells you we have a double bond,
and it starts at the
number three carbon, goes from
the three to the four carbon.
But this isn't just a regular
alkene, this is
a carboxylic acid.
So instead of writing that final
e, for an alkene, we
write it as we have a carboxyl
group right here, so this is 3
heptenoic acid.
And we are done.
Actually if you wanted to get
really fancy on this one right
over here, you could see that
these two carbons that are on
the double bond, so this carbon
and this carbon, it's
kind of a range like this.
Let me draw it like this.
They both have other hydrogens
off there that we didn't draw,
they're implicitly there.
But if you wanted to rewrite or
redraw this molecule, you
could draw it like this.
You have two carbons,
just like this.
This one has a hydrogen popping
up like that; that one
has a hydrogen popping
down like that.
And then this carbon over
here has this big
functional group over here.
We'll call that R.
And then this one over here--
I'll do it in green-- has this
other functional group, has
these three carbons.
We can call that R prime.
And if you look at it this way,
the functional groups are
on opposite sides of
the double bond.
They're away from each other.
So if you wanted to, you could
also call this trans 3
heptenoic acid.
And this will specify
that these guys
are on opposite ends.
But this is only if you're
assuming that I drew it in the
actual three dimensional
configuration in some way.
Anyway, hopefully you
found that useful.